Bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo dans laquelle je vais vous parler du
développement personnel.
Donc préparez vous un petit café, un thé...
Installez-vous confortablement, on va prendre le temps d'expliquer les choses tranquillement
et on se retrouve tout de suite après le générique.
C'est parti !
Le développement personnel
c'est un sujet très vaste, très compliqué,
sur lequel, il faut bien le dire, on entend
un petit peu tout et n'importe quoi, et notamment
par des personnes qui ne connaissent pas vraiment le sujet, c'est-à-dire qui ne l'ont pas expérimenté.
Donc pour avoir étudié et
expérimenté le développement personnel,
je pense avoir une légitimité à en parler,
et je vais donc vous livrer mon point de vue dans cette vidéo. Un point de vue
qui n'est que mon point de vue, qui ne se veut pas une vérité objective.
Ce sera simplement une analyse personnelle de ce phénomène, parce que je pense que
le développement personnel doit d'abord être vu comme un phénomène, il doit être interprété comme tel,
avant de voir ce qu'il peut avoir d'utile, ou pas,
dans telle ou telle circonstance.
Alors qu'est ce que le développement personnel ?
On pourrait dire que c'est un ensemble de méthodes,
un ensemble de techniques,
d'approches, qui permettent une amélioration
et une transformation de soi.
On pourrait dire également qui permettent une exploitation
au plus haut niveau de son potentiel.
Vous voyez que cette définition, elle est déjà en soi problématique, parce que lorsqu'on parle
d'"amélioration de soi", lorsqu'on parle de
"réaliser son potentiel",
on ne sait pas exactement dans quel domaine on parle.
Eh bien justement, le développement personnel
s'applique à tous les domaines.
On peut l'utiliser dans le domaine professionnel, pour atteindre des objectifs professionnels,
mais également dans le domaine plus personnel, justement,
par exemple : sentimental, amical,
social... On peut utiliser le développement personnel, par exemple, pour vaincre sa timidité,
pour être plus audacieux dans nos rapports aux autres,
également pour lever certains blocages mentaux qui nous empêchent de réaliser nos projets, qui nous empêchent
d'atteindre nos objectifs.
Alors j'aimerais d'abord parler du développement personnel comme d'un symptôme, un symptôme de notre époque
puisque c'est un phénomène qui est
en réalité assez récent.
Lorsqu'on l'étudie, on s'aperçoit que le développement personnel a été formalisé à partir du XXe siècle
avec des ramifications dans
la psychologie du XIXe siècle,
mais ça reste un phénomène assez moderne et assez récent. Et donc, pour bien comprendre
ce phénomène, il faut le remettre en perspective,
il faut le réinscrire dans un contexte qui va nous permettre d'en comprendre la signification.
Il y a quelques jours, j'ai fait un entretien avec une coach en développement personnel,
dans lequel je lui faisais remarquer que
le développement personnel ne peut naître
que dans une société
où la problématique de la survie
a été résolue, a été réglée.
Le développement personnel, finalement, c'est un peu un privilège, c'est-à-dire qu'on peut se poser la question
de l'amélioration de soi quand on n'a plus à se poser la question de comment on va se nourrir
ou comment on va s'abriter
pour pouvoir survivre.
Donc
c'est déjà quelque chose qui correspond
à une situation
sociologique de privilégiés. Et je pense que c'est important de le préciser et de l'assumer, de ne pas faire comme si ce n'était pas vrai.
Sociologiquement,
on entre dans le développement personnel
quand on n'a pas d'autres problèmes. Lorsqu'on est
dans les tranchées pendant la guerre, lorsqu'on doit se lever à 5 heures du matin pour aller cultiver son champ,
le développement personnel est quelque chose de
très secondaire, pour ne pas dire absurde.
Ça n'a pas de sens de se poser la question de comment s'améliorer,
de comment
avoir une meilleure connaissance de soi, par exemple,
lorsqu'on est confronté à la dureté de la vie, à la dureté de la réalité.
Une fois qu'on a dit ça, il faut aller plus loin, c'est-à-dire qu'il ne s'agit pas
simplement de se moquer des personnes qui ont recours au développement personnel en disant :
"Ces personnes-là n'ont aucun problème dans leur vie et du coup ça mérite simplement notre mépris".
Non ! Je pense que ça dit quelque chose
de beaucoup plus profond
sur le besoin qu'a tout être humain
que sa vie ait du sens, tout simplement.
Je pense qu'on ne peut pas reprocher à un être humain
de rechercher du sens,
de vouloir que sa vie ait un sens. Et quand ce sens n'apparaît pas de manière explicite, de manière directe,
ce sens, on va aller le rechercher, et on va notamment le rechercher à l'intérieur de soi. Et c'est là, à mon avis
qu'apparaît
la légitimité du développement personnel.
C'est à ce moment-là que le développement personnel commence à avoir du sens.
Pourquoi a-t-on besoin de sens ?
Parce que dans une société de l'abondance,
dans une société de l'opulence où évidemment
il y a des inégalités,
évidemment il y a des personnes qui ont
des conditions de vie infiniment
plus difficiles que d'autres,
mais d'une manière générale,
même les gens assez pauvres,
même les gens défavorisés
arrivent à survivre.
Et malgré ça,
ça peut ne pas suffire.
On a malgré tout un besoin de sens, on a un besoin
d'immatériel, on pourrait même aller jusqu'à dire
de transcendance
qui ne peut pas être satisfait
dans le confort matériel de nos sociétés.
On a beau avoir le dernier iPhone, on a beau avoir
un équipement matériel
qui fait qu'on a tout à disposition, on a notre abonnement Netflix, notre abonnement Internet,
on a une télévision, on a une voiture,
tout ce que vous voulez...
Ça ne suffit pas à combler le besoin de sens
qui existe en tout être humain.
Et le fait de nier cette dimension immatérielle,
cette dimension transcendante de l'être humain,
je pense que c'est une erreur.
Tout simplement parce que
ça fait partie intégrante de nous,
et vouloir nous l'enlever, c'est simplement
prendre le risque que ce besoin
s'exprime dans autre chose.
Dans l'entretien que j'ai réalisé avec Marika, où on parlait du développement personnel, je lui disais (et je maintiens) que pour certaines personnes,
le sens va être trouvé dans le développement personnel, et pour d'autres, il va être trouvé, par exemple,
dans l'engagement politique.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que la politique, c'est une manière de donner
du sens à sa vie en s'engageant,
en mettant sa personne au service
d'une cause supérieure,
donc d'une cause transcendante.
Et on pourra
dire tout ce qu'on voudra des personnes
qui s'engagent en politique,
des militants, quel que soit leur bord, quelles que soient leurs opinions, quelles que soient les valeurs
au nom desquelles ils se battent,
ils se battent toujours pour du sens,
ils se battent toujours pour un idéal :
l'idéal d'une société juste,
l'idéal d'une société dans laquelle
tout le monde serait heureux.
N'importe quel dictateur, le plus infâme,
va toujours agir au nom d'un certain idéal,
au nom d'une certaine conception du bien.
Et ça, c'est un comportement
lié à la transcendance, lié au besoin de sens.
Et je maintiens, là encore, que c'est quelque chose
que nous avons tous en nous, ce besoin de sens,
et que l'on va l'exprimer de différentes manières.
Aujourd'hui, dans une société comme la nôtre,
une société
matériellement confortable, une société de l'abondance,
le sens
ne saute plus aux yeux.
Lorsqu'on doit survivre et lutter pour la survie,
ça a du sens, ça a forcément du sens. Et
on n'est pas soumis, on n'est pas sujets
à la dépression et au questionnement
lorsque notre quotidien est une lutte pour la survie.
C'est à partir du moment où
on a plus de combats à mener,
c'est à partir du moment où on n'a
plus rien à conquérir, plus rien à obtenir
que l'on va essayer de trouver du sens dans
le développement personnel. Voilà pourquoi
avant de se moquer des personnes qui s'intéressent
au développement personnel ou qui le pratiquent,
on ferait bien de se poser la question de
pourquoi est-ce que ces personnes
s'y intéressent ?
Qu'est-ce qui les amène, qu'est-ce qui les conduit
vers ce chemin ? Et là, on comprendra que  c'est avant tout le besoin de sens.
Une fois qu'on a dit ça,
qu'on a fait cette petite analyse d'ordre
"philosophico-sociologique"
je pense que c'est aussi intéressant de s'intéresser
au développement personnel en tant que tel,
de ce qu'il peut apporter à l'individu
et de se demander si c'est quelque chose qui relève
de la charlatanerie ou si c'est quelque chose qui, au contraire, peut avoir des effets bénéfiques.
Alors déjà, de quel développement personnel est-ce qu'on parle ? Comme je vous l'ai dit,
il y a plusieurs mouvements, il y a plusieurs approches
de ce développement personnel,
et en fait on va trouver absolument
tout et n'importe quoi.
On aura des formes de développement personnel,
par exemple,
qui seront très axées sur la spiritualité,
voire l'ésotérisme, le symbolisme, le mysticisme
par exemple,
une approche quasi religieuse, mais j'emploie
le mot religion sans aucune connotation péjorative.
Mais on peut aussi avoir une
approche beaucoup plus pragmatique du développement personnel, qui va reposer simplement
sur des rituels : des rituels de vie, des rituels d'action.
Et
il n'y a pas d'opposition entre ces deux approches.
C'est simplement une question de sensibilité.
Parce que lorsqu'on approfondit le sujet, on s'aperçoit que les choses sont totalement liées,
et pour ça je vais prendre un exemple
qui est un courant philosophique
que je vous invite à découvrir, qui s'appelle le pragmatisme. Donc là on a le livre de William James
et William James était un psychologue américain, psychologue et philosophe,
et il a introduit cette notion de pragmatisme en philosophie (donc c'est un Américain)
pour dire que : tout ce qui concerne la vie de l'esprit
se répercute fatalement dans la vie concrète,
dans la matière,
et qu'il n'y a pas de séparation
entre les deux sphères.
Et que donc, selon lui,
ce qui est vrai sur le plan théorique
est aussi vrai sur le plan pratique
et inversement,
c'est-à-dire que ce qui fonctionne dans la pratique
est forcément vrai en théorie.
En France, nous fonctionnons sur l'idée d'une séparation entre le domaine matériel et le domaine spirituel.
Et d'ailleurs, il n'y a qu'à voir la réaction
que peuvent avoir des personnes
dès qu'on commence à parler de problématiques matérielles, dès qu'on commence à parler
de problématiques financières par exemple,
de problématiques
concrètes,
prosaïques...Tout de suite, ces personnes-là
vont être scandalisées
que l'on puisse
entacher
la philosophie, que l'on puisse entacher
la vie intellectuelle
par des considérations aussi basses, aussi viles que l'argent, que le gain matériel, que le confort matériel,
que de simples objets.
On m'a, par exemple,
l'entretien avec Frédéric Delavier était très intéressant de ce point de vue-là : des personnes ont reproché à Frédéric Delavier,
alors qu'il était en train d'expliquer
comment la conscience a émergé chez l'Homme
et comment cette conscience amène chez l'Homme
l'idée de Dieu,
alors même qu'il était en train de parler de ce sujet,
certains étaient en train de commenter
et de l'insulter parce qu'il portait
un T-shirt avec son nom marqué dessus ou parce qu'il
était en train de boire une canette de Monster.
Donc à ce moment-là j'ai envie de dire :
qui a un problème avec
la dimension matérielle ? Est-ce que ce sont les personnes qui acceptent de vivre dans la matière
ou est ce que ce sont les personnes qui s'offusquent que l'on puisse mêler du matériel au spirituel,
dans le spirituel ?"
Parce qu'après tout, nous sommes tous des êtres de chair, nous sommes tous des êtres incarnés.
Nous ne sommes pas des entités flottantes, éthériques,
qui seraient pures, qui seraient intactes de toute corruption matérielle. Non ! Nous sommes des êtres
corruptibles, comme disait Platon,
et à partir de là, nous devons assumer,
endosser notre dimension matérielle.
Et le développement personnel
assume, en réalité,
cette nature de l'homme,
qui est à la fois spirituelle et matérielle.
Ce développement personnel va nous permettre de concilier les deux, de concilier nos aspirations
transcendantes et spirituelles avec notre vie pratique.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose de fondamental parce que
cela rejoint, selon moi, la véritable définition
de l'activité philosophique
qui est de faire coïncider
sa vie pratique avec son idéal, ses idéaux
spirituels, intellectuels, philosophiques ou moraux.
Et d'ailleurs,
les philosophes stoïciens, pour parler d'eux,
dans l'antiquité
avaient déjà, d'une certaine manière,
compris ça.
Et leur approche peut nous faire penser à un embryon
du développement personnel. Alors évidemment je ne mets pas sur le même plan la philosophie stoïcienne et le développement personnel.
Je dis simplement que ce n'est pas absurde
de faire un rapprochement.
Ce n'est pas absurde de voir un lien et de se dire que
le développement personnel s'est "nourri"
de cette philosophie
de l'antiquité, de cette philosophie stoïcienne,
dans laquelle il n'y avait pas de séparation entre
le corps et l'esprit,
dans laquelle on envisage l'être humain
dans sa globalité, dans son intégralité,
et
dans laquelle
(cette philosophie, le stoïcisme)
on préconise que l'homme agisse en conformité
avec
sa vie philosophique, avec ses idées, avec ses valeurs.
Le développement personnel,
c'est ce qui va permettre
de concrétiser
ce que l'on a dans l'esprit.
Et c'est là où on arrive à quelque chose que certaines personnes ont parfois du mal à comprendre :
c'est l'idée que la réalité dépend, en grande partie,
de la pensée qui dirige notre action.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire que si on a une approche purement déterministe du monde, on va dire
"chaque cause produit un effet
et nous n'avons pas de liberté",
on se condamne de facto à être passif dans l'existence. Parce qu'après tout à quoi bon
entreprendre, à quoi bon prendre des initiatives,
à quoi bon faire preuve d'audace puisque de toute façon
le résultat
sera le même, le résultat est déjà
prévu, programmé à l'avance ? Donc quoi qu'on fasse, quoi qu'on dise, quoi qu'on veuille, ça ne changera rien.
Voilà pourquoi le déterminisme en philosophie,
même si selon moi il est valide sur le plan
de l'explication des phénomènes du monde, il devient un handicap, un frein dans l'action.
Le développement personnel va consister à dire que nous ne sommes pas les esclaves du déterminisme
au sens où
on
conserve un pouvoir
d'influencer le monde et d'agir sur nous-mêmes.
Le développement personnel part du principe que
nous avons en nous un potentiel.
Un potentiel d'amélioration, un potentiel
de transformation de soi qui peut nous rendre heureux.
Et c'est ça la finalité première
du développement personnel
c'est de nous rendre heureux.
Et vous voyez que le développement personnel,
de ce point de vue-là, n'est rien d'autre
que
un projet d'amélioration de la société,
mais qui passe d'abord par soi.
En s'améliorant soi-même, on contribue à l'amélioration
du bien commun, on contribue à l'amélioration
de la société, du collectif, donc indirectement du monde.
Voilà pourquoi le développement personnel
ne me semble pas pouvoir être réduit à
une vision égoïste du monde, à une vision
autocentrée du monde.
Certes, c'est une vision individualiste dans le sens où
l'individu est posé comme étant premier,
en tout cas, premier dans l'ordre
du changement : on se change d'abord soi-même avant de vouloir changer le monde. Et vous remarquerez que
c'est peut-être moins
autocentré, c'est peut-être beaucoup moins narcissique
que de vouloir changer le monde sans se poser
la question de se changer soi-même.
Après tout, lorsqu'on veut changer le monde sans
se poser la question de ce que l'on est
ou de ce que l'on vaut,
sans se poser la question, par exemple,
de sa légitimité à vouloir changer le monde : qui est-on
pour vouloir changer le monde et le rendre
conforme à nos aspirations personnelles ?
Est-ce que ce n'est pas finalement ça, une démarche
narcissique ?
Est-ce que ce n'est pas vouloir changer le monde sans se poser la question de se changer soi-même ?
Donc
ça c'est quelque chose qui me semble important à rappeler : le développement personnel
est un ensemble d'outils
qui nous fait prendre conscience
que
si on lève un certain nombre de barrières mentales,
un certain nombre de blocages psychologiques,
un certain nombre de préjugés :
préjugés sociaux,
préjugés moraux, préjugés philosophiques,
(puisque nous avons tous une philosophie inconsciente),
si on enlève tout ça, tout devient possible.
Quand je dis que tout devient possible, évidemment
si je me jette de mon balcon en espérant m'envoler,
j'ai de fortes chances de le regretter parce que ça n'est pas possible, physiquement ce n'est pas possible.
Par contre, si je décide
d'interrompre mes études
de commerce, de marketing,
pour devenir astronaute, pour devenir médecin, pour devenir avocat, pour devenir tout ce que vous voulez,
en réalité rien ne l'empêche.
Rien ne s'y oppose dans la matière,
ça ne contredit pas les lois physiques.
Et à partir du moment où cela ne contredit pas
les lois physiques, c'est possible !
Oui, cela peut contredire une certaine forme de déterminisme social qui nous dit que
il faut être issu d'un certain milieu pour accéder
à certaines positions sociales.
Ça, c'était l'analyse de Bourdieu sur la reproduction :
les fils d'ouvriers
deviennent ouvriers,
les fils de médecins deviennent médecins...
Voilà plus ou moins, pour caricaturer,
la position de Bourdieu.
Peut-être qu'à l'échelle collective c'est exact,
ça se constate et ça se vérifie. Mais l'individu
qui est en questionnement sur lui-même,
l'individu qui est en position de choisir son avenir,
de définir des objectifs
et de les accomplir,
s'il part de cette position déterministe,
il est clair qu'il ne fera rien, et il est clair qu'il vivra
toute sa vie avec une frustration qui l'empêchera
d'atteindre ce bonheur.
Imaginez un sportif à qui on dirait par exemple :
"De toute façon, si tu affrontes cet adversaire, il est certain que tu vas perdre."
À ce moment-là, le sport lui-même n'a plus de sens, puisque le sport, c'est aussi
le défi,
c'est le fait de
chercher toujours à repousser ses limites,
c'est le fait de rechercher toujours
à s'améliorer,
à aller au delà de ses capacités.
Donc le développement personnel,
c'est ce que pratique le sportif.
C'est ce que pratique le sportif qui se dit intérieurement : "Je vais le battre, je vais gagner
et rien ne m'en empêchera !"
Et donc le sportif est obligé de se mettre
dans un état mental et psychologique
particulier qui va lui permettre de mobiliser
des ressources pour atteindre son objectif.
C'est donc un auto-conditionnement
qui fonctionne sur le principe de la croyance.
Parce que la croyance,
c'est un moteur.
Et même si cette croyance est une illusion,
au sens où la croyance
ne correspond pas à la réalité matérielle : la croyance
est propre à notre pensée, à notre imagination...
Cette croyance peut avoir des vertus,
et une croyance peut être utile. Et c'est là qu'on rejoint le pragmatisme de William James, qui disait que
tout est croyance.
Et qu'à partir du moment où tout est croyance,
il y a des croyances utiles, il y a des croyances
inutiles, voire nuisibles.
Si vous avez une croyance qui a
des effets positifs dans votre vie,
cette croyance devient vraie.
C'est ça la position pragmatique
(ou pragmatiste),
c'est ça l'idée développée dans ce courant.
Alors là, évidemment, j'entends tout de suite
arriver ceux qui vont dire : "Mais n'importe quoi !
Mais comment peut-on dire qu'une croyance est vraie
alors même qu'on sait que la croyance ne repose
sur aucun fondement,
qu'elle n'ait pas vérifié par la pratique,
par les faits, par l'observation ?!"
Mais ça, c'est un schéma de pensée
qu'on n'est pas obligé de suivre.
On peut choisir
l'illusion de soi, on peut choisir la croyance,
dès lors que cette croyance va être mobilisatrice.
Et d'ailleurs, il ne s'agit pas forcément d'une illusion.
Si je dis, par exemple, que je souhaite devenir
astrophysicien,
je sais très bien que je ne le serai pas demain.
Mais je sais très bien que dès demain,
je peux entamer les démarches pour le devenir.
Et ça, est-ce que ça relève de l'illusion ou
de la croyance ? Non !
Ça relève simplement d'un constat factuel.
Je peux entrer dans un processus d'étude, dans une démarche qui va me permettre d'atteindre cet objectif.
Qu'est-ce qui me l'empêche ?
Rien ne me l'empêche !
C'est ça, le développement personnel !
C'est prendre conscience que
de par notre éducation, de par notre vie en société,
nous avons intériorisé un certain nombre de croyances
limitantes, croyances auto-limitantes, qui nous empêchent, en réalité, de nous battre
pour atteindre nos objectifs.
Et ce faisant on crée une société de la passivité
et donc une société de la frustration
dans laquelle on va
critiquer, dénoncer, jalouser parfois
ceux qui atteignent leurs objectifs,
comme si le fait d'atteindre ses objectifs
était la preuve d'un comportement suspect,
était la preuve d'un comportement louche,
d'un comportement pas forcément éthique...
"Ça cache quelque chose quand quelqu'un réussit",
c'est ça qu'on se dit.
On a ce réflexe intégré en nous
de mettre de la suspicion
dès lors que quelqu'un a réussi quelque chose
que nous n'avons pas réussi à faire.
Le développement personnel part du principe que :
au lieu de critiquer, au lieu de jalouser ou de dénoncer,
on peut soi-même devenir acteur et mettre en place
les actions et les moyens pour atteindre ses objectifs.
Ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va forcément y arriver.
Ça veut dire qu'il est certain qu'on n'y arrivera pas
si on ne met rien en place pour y arriver.
C'est ça, le message principal du développement personnel ! En tout cas,
d'une certaine approche du développement personnel, parce que je vous l'ai dit,
il y a mille et une façons, en réalité, d'entrer dans
le développement personnel.
Donc vous voyez que ce qu'on appelle la croyance, en fait, n'est pas forcément là où on pense qu'elle est.
On dira que les personnes qui pratiquent
le développement personnel
sont soumises à des croyances.
C'est ce qui fait que dès qu'on parle de développement personnel, tout de suite on entend,
en arrière-fond,
les mots de :
"escrocs", "charlatans",
"dérives sectaires",
"gourous"...
c'est-à-dire des mots qui vont aller jouer sur la peur,
qui vont aller jouer sur
ce cerveau reptilien qui va nous mettre en insécurité,
au lieu de se demander tout simplement :
qu'est ce qu'il y aurait à retirer de bénéfique dans ces pratiques ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait qu'autant de personnes vont vers
le développement personnel
s'il n'y a pas quelque chose à en retirer ?
Et ça permettrait d'améliorer
toutes ces techniques plutôt que de simplement
considérer ceux qui y recourent comme des pestiférés
ou des personnes manipulables, influençables
ou qui n'ont pas de cerveau.
La croyance n'est pas forcément
là où on pense qu'elle est.
Qu'est ce qui relève de la croyance ?
Est-ce que c'est le fait de se dire
qu'on est capable, demain,
d'entamer les démarches pour devenir astrophysicien, pour devenir
bûcheron, pour devenir boulanger pour devenir tout ce que vous voulez ? Est-ce que c'est ça, la croyance ?
Ou est-ce que c'est le fait de présupposer que
de toute façon, quoi qu'on fasse, on n'y arrivera pas
et que ça ne sert à rien de vouloir contredire
les lois du déterminisme social, que ça ne sert à rien
de vouloir s'opposer au schéma, au conformisme,
de dire que c'est peine perdue,
que c'est perdu d'avance ?
Est-ce que ce n'est pas ça la croyance ?
Est-ce que la croyance, ce n'est pas le fait d'affirmer quelque chose sans avoir aucune preuve
et
simplement de considérer que
l'individu est impuissant,
que le poids de la société est trop écrasant pour que l'individu ait son mot à dire ?
C'est ça qui relève de la croyance ! Parce que ça relève d'une confusion absolument totale entre
les lois du déterminisme social
qui nous gouvernent collectivement
et notre rapport individuel à nous-mêmes
qui n'a strictement rien à voir avec ces lois.
Le monde est fait de cas particuliers,
au sens où chacun va vivre différemment et individuellement son rapport au monde.
D'une manière collective, d'une manière générale,
effectivement, on respecte ce schéma,
consciemment ou non, en tout cas
le schéma déterministe se vérifie
à une échelle collective, c'est exact.
Mais vous qui êtes en train de m'écouter actuellement,
vous qui, peut-être, entendez mes paroles et vous dites : "Ça a du sens pour moi, ça fait écho à certaines choses
sur lesquelles je me suis déjà interrogé(e)."
Vous,
qu'est-ce qui vous empêche
de mettre en place des choses
pour améliorer votre vie concrète,
matérielle, mais aussi
spirituelle, votre connaissance de soi,
votre connaissance du monde ?
J'ai fait énormément de vidéos pour vous inciter,
par exemple,
à lire des philosophes.
Je parlais tout à l'heure du stoïcisme.
Le stoïcisme est une philosophie du développement personnel, dans le sens où c'est une philosophie extrêmement concrète
qui va avoir des répercussions dans votre rapport
au monde, dans votre rapport aux autres,
qui va vous apporter une forme de sérénité
par l'acceptation et par la compréhension
et qui va vous permettre de bien faire la distinction
entre le possible et l'impossible.
Il y a une phrase d'un Stoïcien qui s'appelle Épictète
qui disait :
"Rien de ce qui est possible à l'homme
ne peut être au-dessus de tes moyens".
Une fois qu'on a compris ça,
on a compris que la question du déterminisme
et de la liberté était un faux problème.
C'est un problème purement intellectuel,
c'est un problème qui n'a pas de réalité matérielle,
dans le sens où, si on a compris ça,
rien ne va nous empêcher de poursuivre
et d'atteindre nos objectifs.
La question que vous pose
le développement personnel, c'est de savoir :
qu'est-ce que vous voulez ? Et quels sont les moyens que vous êtes prêt(e) à mettre en place
pour y arriver, pour atteindre vos objectifs ?
Et quand je parle d'objectifs,
je parle d'objectifs au sens très général.
C'est ce que vous aurez identifié ,vous,
comme étant un objectif.
Peut-être que pour vous,
rencontrer des gens dans un lieu, dans un bar
par exemple,
au théâtre ou peu importe,
et vous adresser à des inconnus,
peut-être que pour vous c'est déjà quelque chose
d'extraordinaire, quelque chose que vous n'envisagez pas. Peut-être que pour vous ça représente
un objectif que vous souhaitez atteindre.
Qu'est ce qui vous en empêche,
concrètement, matériellement ?
Rien, et vous le savez !
Donc le développement personnel va peut-être vous donner des outils pour vous mettre en confiance
et pour apprendre et comprendre
qu'en fait vous avez le pouvoir
d'accomplir ce que vous désirez.
C'est un objectif qui peut paraître dérisoire pour certaines personnes. Certains vont peut-être se moquer de cet exemple parce qu'ils ne comprennent pas
que les objectifs sont propres à chacun
et que l'amélioration de soi, ça passe aussi par
combattre tout ce qui fait blocage en nous,
combattre tout ce qui nous empêche d'être serein,
combattre tout ce qui fait qu'on aura
toujours une boule au ventre,
une appréhension,
une gêne à faire telle ou telle chose.
Alors qu'on sait très bien qu'en réalité,
on pourrait le faire.
Tout simplement parce qu'on voit d'autres le faire,
mais qu'on s'interdit de le faire.
Le développement personnel
est une manière de lever ces interdictions
et de vous dire :
"Toi aussi, tu peux. Toi aussi, tu as le droit.
Donc toi aussi, vas-y, fonce !"
Voilà, il y aurait énormément de choses à dire
que je n'ai pas abordées dans cette vidéo sur ce sujet
mais peut-être que je consacrerai
une prochaine vidéo pour revenir
sur vos questions par exemple.
Si vous avez des questions,
des demandes de précisions,
vous pouvez les laisser dans les commentaires.
N'oubliez pas de me suivre sur les réseaux sociaux :
ma page Facebook, mon compte Instagram.
Et un grand MERCI du fond du cœur à toutes
les personnes qui me soutiennent sur Tipeee.
On se dit à bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
et surtout : soyez sages ;)